so someone asked me to share what my
four to six best game-changing
eye-opening tips or advice that I want
people to implement to create a business
and a life that matters and I thought
I'm going to turn this into a video for
you guys as well and I hope this helps
you and you find some value in it so
here we go my 6th best game-changing
tips number one most people's lives and
their businesses are mediocre they wake
up and drive to a job that they don't
really like to do work that is beneath
them they want to spend their time doing
more meaningful work but they can't
define what that meaningful work looks
like we want to be a part of something
great but they don't actually believe
that they have greatness within them
finding your one word is the path to
self awareness standing for something
important and breaking the chains of
mediocrity in all areas of your life and
business number to stop selling features
and benefits start core selling most
businesses sell inefficiently people
want to know what you stand for and what
kind of company you are before they buy
from you most salespeople either sell
the features of their products and
services or the benefits connected to
them lead with the mission lead with
your why lead with your values lead with
your one word customers will come to you
buy more and refer their friends because
you're making them feel like they are
part of an important mission as well
that's core selling number three find
your one word your one word is the lens
to which you see the world it's your
guide to help you make the right
decisions fania is one of the most
important journeys you'll ever go on in
your life you start by asking yourself
what makes you happy and trying to find
a common theme between what your
favorite movie is who your favorite
bosses and the activities that make you
feel most alive you can also go negative
and think about the people situations
and actions that you just can't stand
being a part of the opposite of that
negative common theme is your one word
to gain extra clarity you can combine
multiple words into one word that
carries extra meaning for you
think about if you've always loved this
one word and always will what values you
may have learned from your parents and
is this who you really are as opposed to
someone you think you should be number
four you must overcome your limiting
beliefs you are where you are because of
what you believe and the limit beliefs
that you own have held you back from
doing big things before and will hold
you back again this time around as well
you tell yourself that having one word
is too bold you'll seek out the opinions
of others instead of listening to
yourself more do you worry that someone
else is using that already and you'll
think it's too simple and can't be put
into a single word stop needlessly
overcomplicating things stopped playing
small stop being ruled by the judgements
and opinions of other people it's time
to finally do something big with your
life embrace it number five apply your
one word to your marketing the easiest
way to get started is to build a
marketing campaign around your one word
if your one word is action for example
what's a credo that defines action for
you and your soon to be emerging
movement what's your action founding
story what will you name your action
tribe what rituals and gestures
represent action what's the name of your
company your logo your font and your
symbols and how do they show action what
or who is the enemy of action and how
can you rally against them what does
action sound like your one word sits as
a layer on top of all the important
decisions that you make and your market
is usually the easiest place to start
because it brings in revenue prove to
yourself that it works in small
increments before you go all-in number
six leverage your one word to build an
empire Mickey more sales is great but
your one word has so much greater
potential for your business it can help
you build an empire the next easiest
place to start is your company culture
let's see there one word is care
applying that to your culture how do you
hire with care how do you onboard new
hires with care how do you create an
environment that screens care what
company rituals will you create that
embodied care what titles names in
language will you use around care what
do care company policies look like how
do you fire with care then you can move
to operations thinking about your client
management
buyer selection products and services
quality control research and development
mentors and advisors raising capital
project management and so on how do you
approach each one through the lens of
care what started off as a personal
journey of self-discovery has become a
galvanizing force that can reshape the
way you do business impact every level
of your company and give the people
around you as well as yourself a cause
to believe in find your one word